[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author Christina
Patterson and former conservative
special advisor Anita wetting so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now only two in at the moment
they're all waiting for that Manchester
City Victory to make that their their
front page but the front of the Sunday
Times reports that allies of Boris
Johnson have abandoned him following his
resignation as MP yesterday they also
claim the former prime minister is
unlikely to seek a new seat as MP
the sun on Sunday reports that
Manchester United and England star
Marcus rashford has split with his
fiancee
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Christina Patterson and Anita whiteang
welcome to both of you
um let's start with the Sunday Times as
I say only a couple of the the papers in
because of the uh football and
Manchester City's uh victory over into
Milan but starting with the Sunday Times
their headline allies abandoned Johnson
as Tori Mutiny Falls flat Christina take
us into this
yes well I suspect this might hurt Boris
Johnson at Teflon skinned though in many
ways he appears to be this headline
because he still seems to be half
clinging to the delusion that everybody
loves him the country loves him
everybody's dying for him to rescue the
Tory party to become Prime Minister
again to make Britain Great again he's
living in some kind of parallel universe
what he doesn't understand is that
people in this country actually really
cared about partygate they didn't take
it as a trivial matter and Sir John
Curtis the um polling expert has also
said that essentially his popularity has
just sunk so he was expecting I think or
at least hoping lots of Tory MPS to
Rally behind him three have resigned
though it seems they resigned more in
Peak over the honors they are not to
getting then um which they'd hoped to
get than uh than anything else back to
sorry to two others have resigned Nadine
Doris and Nigel Adams
um but it this seems a bit like the The
Windsor uh framework that he was again
hoping to Rally lots of support to his
side and against Rishi sunak and it's
not happening so whether he will ever
face up to the fact that his moment for
being prime minister has gone I don't
know but I I absolutely think his moment
of being prime minister has gone thank
goodness and although he will continue
to try to destabilize Suna the Tory
party the country
Etc from the sidelines I really don't
think he's ever going to be riding back
into power
Anita that the paper claims that uh
source is close to Johnson claimed that
up to six more conservative MPS would
stand down but a number of his
supporters quickly rule themselves out
of any coordinated
um plot so do you think that um perhaps
it was certain that that six or more
would also lead but they've decided
against it they've changed their minds
I always think when it comes to the sort
of briefings to the papers it's more in
Hope than in plotting
um and I would have been surprised if we
saw that volume of resignations
um as Christina says it seems like the
two resignations are possibly more
connected to the wranglings with the
house um with the committee that decides
on whether or not the prime minister's
appointment to the House of Lords are
acceptable or not and the House of Lords
um the the house laws committee that
looks at these appointments effectively
said no to quite a few more than would
normally be the case um and including
according to reports one for Nadine
Doris and another for Nigel Adams so it
may be much more connected to that than
a concerted effort to sort of
destabilize the party
and Christina in terms of um Rishi sunak
this is uh it's a bit of a headache
isn't it really
sorry to laugh but um I mean Boris
Johnson of course is very keen to be a
headache for Rishi sunak and it is a
headache for British season there's a
very interesting story also in the
Sunday Times tomorrow by Tim Shipman
giving more background on this story and
in fact it appears that the Nadine Doris
and Nigel Adams and also Alex Sharma
um who were all expecting to get um
peerages from Boris Johnson and told
they would get periods from Boris
Johnson it appears to have been his
usual lack of attention to detail that
has scuppered that because apparently
um he would they would have had to
resign within six months
um and they he vaguely thought that they
could have their
um that they could have their selections
kind of read their nominations kind of
revived uh in six months time and that's
not the case so I think as always Boris
Johnson is seeing conspiracies where
there weren't any and I think the thing
has not actually been by the committee
but oh by Richie sunac but through this
technicality that Boris Johnson didn't
take the trouble to understand
so you know as always it's a kind of
yeah laziness on his part really lack of
attention to detail but I do think it's
over for him and I think that he will be
a real pain in the backside to Rishi
sunak but I don't think that's going to
have a massive impact on the next
election or Rishi sunak's future I just
don't think Boris Johnson is the potent
force in the Tory party that he thinks
he is Anita what are your thoughts on
that because the sons are inviting us to
better Fiverr on Boris Johnson making a
comeback
maybe even before the next election
yes and they have a rather Punchy
article from Mr James dudridge an MP who
is a close Ally of Boris Johnson that
has in it sort of a rundown of his um
Greatest Hits
um and includes a quote saying
um that he's walked off the pitch rather
than being red carded by a Sunday League
ref and as well worth a read
um for Jay's colorful language I think
that ultimately with Boris Johnson it's
a kind of well-worn Trope that you
should sort of never rule Boris Johnson
out but I do think that I cannot see the
kind of benefit to Boris Johnson and his
reputation particularly as a winner for
him to attempt to remain in Parliament
in in any context in terms of trying to
seek another seat that may become free
as a result of these by-elections all
come free in the next sort of year and a
bit before the general election it's
it's hard to remember now but Boris
Johnson really hasn't lost an election
since sort of 9 1997 I think when he
stood
um in a sort of no-ho pursuit for the
conservatives and so I think that the
part of the the compelling Mythos that
we see in this article again from James
dodridge in the sun is that Boris
Johnson is a born winner who can connect
with the electorate not like no other
and I think if Boris Johnson were to see
that um you know scuppered uh either in
the cases we've seen with ux in Uxbridge
where whether it's recall petition or
the by-election that might have resulted
or indeed the involved in Parliament he
may well have come a Cropper and he's
shown himself to say well actually I'm
just not going to play and I'm taking
back control I'm I'm going up into the
sunset and not to be forced otherwise so
I'm a little skeptical that we are going
to see the The Comeback and if I are a
gambling woman and I'm not I would take
not that bit of a fiber
okay let's um talk about another
troubled politician actually um Donald
Trump the son um is uh running this
piece but also we heard from him the
first time since his indictment this
this evening Christina
yeah well I was naive enough to be uh
delighted when I heard that um he was
being
um going to be appearing in court on
um for indicting being indicted sorry
because of 37 documents that appear to
have uh broken uh highly classified
documents that he kept in various places
in Mara logo including the shower the
bathroom I mean that and some of these
had nuclear uh information about sort of
nuclear secrets it's kind of
breathtaking stuff and you would think
that that would be enough if just you
would think that the very fact that he
is being tried on such incredibly
serious stages which charges which you
know pretty much amount to espionage or
you know kind of aiding and abetting
Espionage because Mara logo is full of
people who come and go and anyone could
have just picked up those documents at
almost any time but you would think this
would count him out for running to be
the most powerful person in the world
again but absolutely shockingly and
disgracefully it doesn't
apparently he can still run for
president
and if he is prosecuted even if he's in
jail which is just kind of
mind-blowingly crazy and what really
struck me actually about and of course
he's now denouncing this as he doesn't
use the phrase Kangaroo Court which
Boris Johnson used yesterday but he is
um of course saying it's all a
conspiracy against him and and Biden is
the most corrupt present ever but what
struck me about Boris Johnson's
um a statement yesterday was how very
Champion it was you know I I think he
doesn't really like being compared to
Trump but he has become more and more
trump-like this idea that there is never
any that any
court or committee or body
democratically elected or appointed
through procedures that in this case
Boris Johnson authorized could could be
correct that he just won't countenance
so it's shocking stuff let us take a
look at the Sun and this story about the
long away server counter-offensive the
uh counter-offensive from Ukraine it is
official now because we've had uh
valensky actually saying so Christina
yes well obviously it's good if um
Ukraine's troops are making progress
they've been planning this counter event
so for a very very long time but I have
to say then the light of what's happened
this week with the kokova dam which is
an absolute tragedy both ecologically
and of course for the all the people
living in the area and for in terms of
food production I mean this is something
that could affect people in Africa the
the consequences are of of what it looks
as if Putin is done with a dam are so
enormous that they really dwarf any
gains that uh that Ukraine have made or
are making and while obviously I mean to
everybody or everybody in this country
pretty much wants Ukraine to win just
making some advances on this particular
front line is not going to get Ukraine
to win and I'm afraid at the moment it's
looking as if this is going to be an
extremely long war and it's very hard to
see an end to it or a way out to it so
you know I'm pleased that there is some
good news but I suspect that this is
just a little bit of good news in in a
context where there is going to be an
awful lot of bad news Anisa do you do
you agree do you see this
counter-offensive as being at the
beginning of the end or not
certainly not at the beginning of the
end and counter apprentices are
particularly risky I think Russia has
found that going on the offensive is
difficult when you're up against a very
determined Defender and I think it will
be the same for Ukraine in this Modern
War
um and Ukraine I mean the thing that
Christina says is really important here
which is just the levels of Destruction
that we're seeing is kind of almost
impossible to describe and it's
interesting that Ukraine for instance
have made a show of kind of going after
bakmut which is a city that uh the
Russians kind of delighted a few months
ago in saying they had captured
effectively let's not forget this entire
city has been reduced to Rubble there
are simply creatures in the middle of
what used to be schools and hospitals
and the entire infrastructure and of the
entire city is destroyed so let's not
forget that through this
counter-offensive which is brought with
risk for Ukraine you could ultimately
end up in a situation where the entire
country is destroyed
um and yes it's definitely going to be a
you know for long fought out offensive
although Ukraine will be hoping to see
some significant
um moves forward by the end of the
summer okay let's um move to this story
this remarkable story of um survival
that the paper's calling it uh the sun
calling it a miracle these are the four
children in the Colombian jungle
um Christina I mean absolutely well I
think it is a miracle
yeah it's incredible and um and thank
goodness to get some good news in the
midst of all of this yes there was a
plane crash in the jungle 40 days ago
and all the adults on the plane were
killed including tragically the parents
of these children but I think
um there was there were sort of pieces
of evidence found in the jungle that
pointed to the fact that the children
might have survived and this rescue
campaign was launched and now the
children have actually been taken to
safety and amazingly are not seriously
injured or seriously ill so it is
absolutely incredible and thank goodness
that occasionally in life amazing things
like this do happen yes and very quickly
um I need to win the vouch you've got
about 20 seconds but the fact that the
youngest is about 12 11 to 12 months
amazing I don't think if I were that 13
year old I would have been able to keep
alive my nine four and yeah less than
one year old
um siblings it's absolutely incredible I
should enroll in a survival course